und jetzt zu einem Fall der uns alle
tief erschüttert und für den ist
eigentlich überhaupt gar keine Worte
gibt das BKA fahndet nach einem
Kinderschänder der mindestens sieben
kleine Jungen schwer missbraucht hat
sein jüngstes Opfer ist gerade einmal
ein Jahr alt die Vergewaltigung hat der
Täter gefilmt und ins Internet gestellt
und über die Jagd nach diesem
Kinderschänder sprechen wir gleich mit
Sebastian Zwiebel vom Cybercrime Center
der Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Frankfurt
zuvor fassen wir aber noch einmal die
wichtigsten Hinweise zusammen
der Mann filmt die fürchterlichen taten
veröffentlicht ihre Aufnahmen im Darknet
IBK Ermittler befürchten dass er sich
auch heute noch an Kindern vergeht
bittet nun die Öffentlichkeit um Hilfe
und zeigen die Tatort der seine
schrecklichen treiben wer kennt diese
Badezimmer einmal ein grünes Wannenbad
einmal ein Badezimmer mit diesem roten
badezimmerläufer auch dieser fluor mit
dem auffälligen roten Koffer spielt eine
Rolle der Täter dürfte zwischen 31 und
51 Jahre alt sein besonders widerlich er
hat vermutlich beruflich oder
ehrenamtlich mit Kindern zu tun auf den
zwischen 2015 und 2019 ins Darknet
gestellten Aufnahmen verwendet der
außerdem oft das Wort Hi als Begrüßung
das BKA veröffentlicht außerdem
Gegenstände die auf dem missbraucht
Bildern zu sehen sind wer erkennt diese
Unterhose mit der Aufschrift 932 Bronx
oder diese gestreiften Socken außerdem
trug eines der Kinder die Pflaster in
Deutschland fahren Design nach der EM
2016 das BKA möchte wissen erkennen Sie
diese kindertaschenlampe verwendet im
März 2019 oder dieser Windelgröße 4
falls Sie sich erinnern bitte melden Sie
sich beim Bundeskriminalamt unter 06115
[Musik]
und uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist Sebastian
Zwiebel vom Cybercrime Center der
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Frankfurt
guten Abend Herr Zwiebel und vielen Dank
dass ihr Zeit für uns haben
lass uns Zeit einsteigen und Anfall
vielleicht können Sie das einmal sagen
wie sind Sie denn auf diesen Täter
gekommen und vor allem wie lange er mit
in die Kollegen schon
na ja den Täter sind wir noch nicht
insofern gekommen als wir wissen um wen
es sich dabei handelt wir sind auf die
Personen also auf
seine Funktion im Darknet gekommen weil
wir
mittlung gegen eine andere Person hatten
und haben ihn als Chatpartner
identifiziert das war im Jahr 2018 als
wir ursprünglich gegen andere Personen
ermittelt haben und im Jahr 2019 haben
sich die Ermittlung auf diese Person
konzentriert ohne das Wissen oder
wussten um wen es sich dabei handelt
dann haben wir relativ lange versucht
eine Entität zu klären das ist uns nicht
gelungen und im Jahr 2020 sind ja mit
und wieder ins Rollen gekommen nachdem
wir die kamera identifizieren
identifiziert haben mit dem er womöglich
einige Bilder gemacht hat und seitdem
sind die Ermittlungen wieder
intensiviert worden hat er denn all
diese Videos mit einem Account Namen
hochgeladen und handelt sich dabei eine
Tauschbörse oder was genau ist das für
ein Forum
aber kann ich dich nicht zu sehr ins
Detail gehen um um keine Anleitung zu
geben aber in der Tat handelt sich um
auf jeden Fall ein bekanntes Forum in
dem er jeden von uns identifiziert wurde
als Chatpartner wie gesagt der Person
die zunächst ins Visier geraten wurde
die auch identifiziert ist die aber sich
über deine Chatpartner nicht einlässt
also keine weiteren Angaben macht so
dass wir jetzt auf die Bevölkerung
angewiesen sind uns bei der
Identifizierung des aktuellen
Beschuldigten zu helfen wie lange sind
denn diese Videosequenzen sind das ein
paar Sekunden oder handelt es sich hier
um mehrere Stunden gefunden Missbrauch
also seien Sie sicher sind
minuten und insgesamt Stunden
unerträglich Materials die unsere
Händler anschauen mussten umso mehr
erfreut werden wir wenn unsere
Ermittlungen zum Erfolg führen und WDT
zertifizieren können sie haben ja gesagt
die kamera das ist also eine wichtige
Spur ein wichtiges Indiz dafür die Spur
nach Berlin Steglitz was können Sie dazu
sagen
haben wir wissen dass die Kamera in
Berlin-Steglitz erworben wurde der
mutmaßliche Täter hat sie bar bezahlt
gab also keine Möglichkeit über eine
mögliche Kreditkartenzahlung auf die
Identität zu kommen mehr wissen wir
allerdings nicht das ist natürlich nicht
sicher dass der Täter auch aus Berlin
stammt theoretisches natürlich möglich
dass über ein Wochenende in Berlin war
oder vielleicht sogar absichtlich ein
Gegenstand in Berlin gekauft hat um eine
falsche Fährte zu legen das ist Teil
unserer Ermittlungen gerade aber auf
jeden Fall ist es ein Indiz sollte
sicher sind dass sie dort in Berlin
gekauft wurde Herr Zwiebel vielen vielen
Dank für dieses Gespräch und voran
drücken wir ihn und den Kollegen
natürlich die Daumen dass sie diesen
Mann schnell schnappen danke schön für
fasons für Sie noch einmal zusammen denn
der Täter der wird auf 31 bis 51 Jahre
geschätzt und vermutlich hat er eben
beruflich oder ehrenamtlich mit Kindern
zu tun wenn sie jetzt Hinweise auf
diesen Kinderschänder haben dann wenden
Sie sich unbedingt an das BKA und bei
der Nummer 06155